[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 26 me suite et fin
de notre série dédiée aux sites
yvelinois qui pourrait accueillir les
jeux olympiques 2024 zoom aujourd'hui
sur le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines candidat
naturel pour la compétition en cas de
sélection française pour les jeux
olympiques elle nicolas bauer est
l'invité de notre émission le conseil
municipal d'elancourt et le suppliant de
mireille brogno pour les élections
législatives sur la 11e circonscription
des yvelines candidat du front libérer
un parti créé il ya quelques semaines
par d'anciens membres du front national
nous évoquerons ses ambitions et le
programme pour cette élection
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons notamment sur la montée en
nationale 3 du club de handball de
plaisir ou encore une exposition néo pop
pour dénoncer la violence à la maison un
trio les arabes
dernier volet je vous le disais de notre
série de reportages réservé aux
différents sites yvelinois qui pourrait
abriter à des épreuves olympiques en
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la structure
qui organisera déjà la ryder cup en 2018
pourrait aussi logiquement recevoir le
tournoi olympique
si la france bien sûr est retenu un
reportage de michael et demi d'eau est
bien mais nous envoie nationale est
ciblé l'open de france vannes quelques
semaines le site de l'open de france
mais pas seulement la structure qui
accueillera déjà la ryder cup en 2018
l'équivalent de la coupe du monde du
golf pourrait également recevoir les
jeux olympiques de 2024 si le dossier
parisien est retenu ce challenge est de
plus c'est une super compétition et dans
les cadres
les yo les ventes nationales serait le
premier parcours du vol du monde andres
et wallons driver cap et les gens
s'adonnent d'émotion à la vie les
joueurs disputeront les parties sur le
parcours de l'albatros le 18 trous
réputé comme l'un des plus compliqués au
monde a été entièrement rénové entre
2015 et 2016 pour organiser la ryder cup
le comité olympique qui a déjà visité le
site à trois reprises se dit séduit il
n'y a pas d'autres sites comme ça au
monde
faut se rappeler que plus que un golf
c'est un stade de golf ça irait qui si
tout a été pensé pour les joueurs oui un
parcours exceptionnel mais aussi pour
les spectateurs et donc on ne retrouve
pas un goal de citer plat au monde donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
cette force qui est la nôtre de pouvoir
accueillir de grandes compétitions et
surtout avec un parcours exceptionnel
les routes nationales ça ce n'est pas
inquiétant car on a on a sur place dès
ya tout ce que c'est les primes et ses
coulisses et on a un hôtel on a en parlé
de top niveau et donc à nos polos ça ce
n'est pas ça ce n'est pas une
préoccupation
forts de leurs 24 open de france
organisé depuis l'ouverture du site en
1990 les dirigeants ont mis en avant
leur expérience des grandes compétitions
pour convaincre le cio la ryder cup 2018
permettra de se roder une nouvelle fois
aux événements internationaux à 6 ans
des jo où l'effet dawala rayak à son
avantage pour n'importe quoi pour venir
dans les footeux c'est comme elle à la
plus grande compétition du monde et on
est très répandu dès que ça va tondre et
aussi le golf national pourrait
accueillir entre 35 et 40 mille
personnes sur le site pour les jeux
olympiques deux fois moins de
spectateurs que pour la ryder cup 2018
le prisme d'elancourt accueilli et il y
a quelques jours douze élèves de
l'agglomération pour s'affronter dans un
concours de menteries
le but du projet est simple raconter une
histoire qui semble réelle jusqu'à une
chute complètement improbable retour sur
cet événement avec camille lambert
tous ces bons secrètement et tout d'un
coup j'étais couverte et écrivent
éléphants de mes patries c'était mon
stylo un stylo qui écrit tout seul
une araignée mangeuse de menteries ou un
arbre à saucisse tous sont le fruit de
l'imagination des élèves de saint
quentin en yvelines
ils étaient douze à présenter leurs
menteries lors d'un concours au prisme
mais au fait c'est quoi une menterie qui
est un mélange de vérité mensonge et
yourtes d'adp est vraisemblable sauf la
fin moi j'ai trouvé ça très dur parce
que qu'ils doivent reprendre à avoir de
l'inspiration
organisé par le réseau des médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines depuis
quatre ans ce concours a réuni cette
année plus de 250 élèves seuls quatre
élus ont été récompensés par le jury
mais raconter ça menteries devant un
public est déjà une grande victoire
le but c'était vraiment d'apprendre aux
enfants à écrire à inventer et ensuite à
passer de l'écrit à l'oral d'abord avec
le support texte mais ensuite d'aller
sur scène sans supporter ex est vraiment
de raconter ce qui est complètement
autre chose
et pour arriver à ce résultat ils ont
été accompagnés par le conteur etienne
il n'y a jamais de mauvaise idée il n'y
a jamais de mauvaises et clients
il ya des choses intéressantes partout
donc j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus c'est
aussi de les mettre en confiance parce
qu'un beau jour ils vont se retrouver
face à un employeur face à un jury
d'examen face à un guichet pour demander
quelque chose et s'exprimaient prendre
la parole c'est très très très important
les 150 menteries seront restitués dans
un livre dans les médiathèques et sur le
site hi média thèque de saint quentin en
yvelines à découvrir avant que
l'araignée mangeuse de menteries ne les
dévore et du cinéma à présent avec le
festival de cannes en septembre dernier
nous vous présentions respire un court
métrage sur le thème de la mucoviscidose
et bien son réalisateur jérôme roumagne
étudiants aux 3 i/s a fait du chemin
depuis puisqu'il est à cannes en ce
moment pour défendre son film inscrit au
short film corner un espace dédié
justement au court métrage
regardez
[Musique]
né à cannes actuellement parce qu'on a
notre court métrage de fin d'études qui
est au short film corner qui a été
accepté au short film corner qui est
donc le marché du premier trajet du
festival de cannes et donc on est venu à
cette occasion avec marie delsart la
scénariste du film pour venir soutenir
le film et rencontrer des professionnels
du cinéma alors respire c'est l'histoire
de
d'antoine un jeune homme de 18 ans qui à
la mucoviscidose et qui est passionné de
course à pied et donc il est à l'hôpital
pour une purée à l'hôpital il va faire
la rencontre d'une vieille dame
totalement acariâtre au fort caractère
et voilà ils ont rien en commun et
pourtant ils vont décider de s'enfuir de
l'hôpital tous lés deux feux
[Musique]
du coup carbon données venir à cannes
pour défendre ce film c'est totalement
inattendu
on pensait pas que le film pouvait venir
à cannes même au short film corner donc
c'était une totale surprise donc mais
que très très content et du coup c'est
l'opportunité pour nous de rencontrer
des professionnels de montrer le film
aussi parce que dans le coup depuis
l'âge quand il décolle on n'a quasiment
pas montrer le film puisque ça doit être
une première mondiale ici donc voilà ça
va être les premiers retours des
professionnels du public des gens qui
vont pouvoir le voir donc c'est un gros
tremplin pour nous et on est très
content d'être d'âtre ici au festival de
cannes alors avant de venir à cannes on
avait une image plutôt papier glacé du
festival c'est à dire qu on savait que
c'était les strass les paillettes les
stars ce genre de choses on pensait pas
qu'il y avait autant d'ateliers de
deux choses pour rencontrer les
professionnels du milieu donc ça ont été
très agréablement surpris de pouvoir
voir que voilà c'était assez accessible
pour pour discuter avec eux pour
échanger avec eux donc donc on a été
surpris l'action s'attendait peut-être
pas à cet aspect là du festival mais
après ça ressemble à un énorme parc
d'attractions une croûte c'est assez
spécial est excitant d'être ici à cannes
d'un retour en plateau avec notre invité
du jour et pour cette émission nicolas
breuer bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
candidat suppléant sur la 11e
circonscription des yvelines pour un
nouveau parti créé récemment le front
libe le front libéré excusez moi est
créée par philippe chevrier ancien
secrétaire départemental du front
national vous êtes vous même ancien
membre du fn pour la petite histoire
vous avez été écarté du parti pour avoir
participé notamment le 1er mai 2016 au
rassemblement organisé par jean marie le
pen
le fonds libérés on aura remarqué le
clin d'oeil dans le non au front
national
comment on peut présenter ce nouveau
parti comme un fn bis un fn proche des
valeurs fondatrices du parti
je vous avez le soutien jean marie le
pen on a le soutien de jean marie le pen
pour les élections législatives
maintenant le front libéré effectivement
au départ c'était un clin d'oeil en
opposition avec le front ligoté parce
que c'est ce qu'on a dénoncé au sein du
front national c'est-à-dire 7,7 façon
autoritaire arbitraire de 2,2 de juger
les cadres qui plaisait pas et des
virées pour des raisons qu'ils étaient
totalement fallacieuse sans cause réelle
et sérieuse
on était viré parce que voilà on a fait
faire un tweet qui avait pas plus on est
viré parce que on va voir jean marie le
pen au 1er mai alors que je rappelle
quand même que jean marie le pen a comme
appeler à voter pour sa fille
voilà qu'il est aussi le créateur du
front national accessoirement
accessoirement bien sûr plus que ces
accessoires dont évidemment faire marine
le pen
elle lui doit tout agent avec quoi vous
êtes vous-même aujourd'hui libérée du
front national qu'elle était pour vous
par exemple problèmes au sein du parti
frontiste c'est ce manque de démocratie
vraiment absolument d'ailleurs la
démocratie est au coeur des du
fonctionnement du franc libéré on a
voulu effectivement mettre cette
démocratie là dans les dents les valeurs
et le fonctionnement du mouvement qu'on
a créés et on est un parti très jeune
c'est voilà ça fait quelques semaines
qu'on existe et je dois dire que j'en
suis assez fier parce que on a on arrive
quand même au bout de quelques semaines
à pouvoir présenter quatre candidats
pour les élections législatives de dans
les grandes lignes voilà deux dans les
yvelines de demander dans l'eure et loir
et tout ça en respectant la parité
enfin je trouve que c'est un exploit
j'imagine que vous suivez encore
l'actualité du front national comme vous
regarder l'actualité du front qui est
assez mouvementée notamment avec ce
score à la présidentielle le second tour
plus bas que prévu avec les problèmes
avec florian philippot ça vous intéresse
à vous ça vous concerne
est ce que ça faisait je forte à votre
position peut-être pas régionales je
pense qu'effectivement on a vu les
choses venir
de loi parce que voilà c'est pas le
lendemain de la présidence qu'on a
dénoncé ces thèmes qu'un bien en l'amour
donc on a vu les choses venir
le résultat ne nous étonne guère vu les
méthodes qui ont été appliquées au sein
du parti est complètement démobilisés
dans certains endroits
les militants faut bien le dire surtout
dans les yvelines
mais je pense que la responsabilité de
l'échec de la fille de jean marie le pen
s'est elle est à chercher chez la fille
de jean-marie le pen et david jean marie
le pen n'est pas marine le pen c'est
volontaire ou basse et c'est sur les 200
nl marine le pen et c'est la fille de
jean louis
d'accord d'accord mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que nos peines et vous
souhaitez c'est une interrogation comme
ça donc
marine le pen a extrêmement a
personnifié cette élection à l'extrême
c'est à dire qu'elle a est là elle a
tout misé sur son prénom elle avait
besoin de lever son nationale elle a
gommé le front national sur les actions
à mener en congé du front national il y
avait plus la flamme du front national
c'est un autre logo
elle disait sur tous les plateaux télé
je ne suis pas la candidate du front
national donc son échec et son échec
personnel
c'est vous désormais le front national
on pourrait dire ça presque puisqu'on
pourrait aller jusque jusque là
puisqu'elle ne met plus le front
national sur ses affiches de campagne
est ce que vous êtes un peu entre
guillemets la nouveau front national à
dire qu'ils ont été virés par le front
national donc je pense que tout est a
changé au front national
nous sommes on a assisté en fait à quoi
une fausse dédiabolisation puisque on à
virey des gens soi disant parce que
c'était la dédiabolisation etc
or on se rend compte en plein de
campagne électorale que elle est
entourée que deux copains d'ailleurs
c'est que ça son petit goût son petit
pré carré c'est les copains et que c'est
des copains les anciens du dard les
anciens de trucs de de gens qu'on peut
qualifier d'extrême droite a quelque
part donc il ya la dédiabolisation
elle est fausse le fonds libérés pour
revenir sur ces élections législatives
présente du coup deux candidats sur les
yvelines 10e et 11e circonscription vous
serez face à des candidats fn parce que
on peut les qualifier d'adversaires
politiques normaux ou alors vous allez
avoir un rapport forcément particulier
avec eux ce sont peut-être des anciens
camarades et on va s'efforcer de les
considérer comme des adversaires normaux
mais c'est clair que il ya un historique
qui fait que oui des gens qu'on connaît
qui sont investis la candidate fn qui se
présentent sur la 11e circonscription
je la connais enfin je la connais je les
croise et on va enfin enfin je la
connais pas tant que ça parce que parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui se présente sous
différents alias donc on sait pas trop à
qui on a affaire
on a vu les instants des candidats sont
là je vois la section donc elle est
parachutée aussi c'est une élue
parisienne qui est parachuté dans la 11e
circonscription dont elle connaît
absolument pas ni les adhérents ni
militant ni les élus ni les enjeux ni
les projets de la circonscription
je crois pas que ce soit une candidature
très sérieuse justement on va parler du
programme quelles sont les différences
entre le front national et sa candidate
aujourd'hui et puis vous le feront
libéré est ce que les idées sont tout de
même assez proches voilà il ya des
grandes différences vous m'avez parlé de
programme vous avez dit vrai alors le
fonds libérés à un programme programme
qui aura vocation à évoluer et à rentrer
dans le détail mais il faut quand même
bien se rappeler qu'une élection
législative c'est c'est pour aller à
l'assemblée nationale c'est pour élire
des députés des députés qui sont là pour
pour voter des lois donc un député va
pas arriver à l'assemblée nationale avec
son programme complet cetera chiffre est
sous le bras vous asseyez je suis élu je
vais pouvoir appliquer mon point ça se
passe pas comme ça donc donc un candidat
les candidats qui qui vont proposer des
programmes est pas hyper complet c'est
du pipeau voilà ce qui est intéressant
est ce qui est important et fondamental
dans une élection législative c'est pas
un mandat exécutif et législatif on vote
des lois
d'accord donc on vote des lois on défend
des idées on défend des valeurs c'est ça
qui est important alors les valeurs
principales pas par exemple d'un point
de vue économique sur votre site
internet il ya remarqué sortie de l'euro
sortis de leur retraite à 65 ans et
retour aux 39 heures ça va peut être une
partie de plaisir permettez moi avec
vous aussi si une majorité change pas le
cas puisque vous avez quatre candidats
mais les idées que vous portez ce ne
sera pas une force à ce que ce que vous
dites sur le côté économique c'est c'est
sur le côté programme d'accord vous
m'avez dit avant de venir ici que de
vous expliquer quels seront les axes
alors les axes allez-y les axes de la
campagne donc ça sera tout d'abord
l'immigration puisque ce sera notre
slogan de
deux campagnes l'immigration assez
d'accord donc les migrations
mais c'est aussi les valeurs les valeurs
fondamentales de la civilisation
française qui sont la liberté l'égalité
la solidarité et la fraternité la
laïcité toutes ces valeurs républicaines
qu'il faut absolument il faut absolument
que les hommes politiques les prennent
ces valeurs là à bras le corps et les
applique dans l'eure dans l'esprit dans
l'esprit de la république et pas
seulement venir sur les plateaux de télé
en disant moi je suis républicain vous
vous êtes pas républicain ça c'est zéro
il faut absolument garder ses idées de
ces valeurs là et c'est à partir de là
qu'on saura si une loi on la votera où
on ne votera pas alors au prénom vous
parliez de lax de l'immigration par
exemple sur votre site internet vous
allez me dire si ça correspond à vos
idées est ce que vous souhaitez porter
je cite en cas de perte de travail de
plus de six mois ou deux condamnations
pénales l'émigré même en règle sera
reconduit dans son pays d'origine et les
mesures nécessaires devront être prises
ma question est simple est-ce qu'on peut
faire ça aujourd'hui en france c'est ce
que la justice nous permet de renvoyer
quelqu'un qui a ses papiers qui est en
règle
ce sera pas forcément nous annonce
encore une fois vous êtes sur le côté
programme
elle part donc nos un député il reçoit
une proposition de loi alors on peut
déposer des propositions de loi dont
général faut avoir un groupe c'est un
peu plus compliqué donc encore une fois
ce programme aura
vocation à évoluer à évoluer les vols et
dans le temps mais effectivement l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on peut pas le faire comme
ça mais c'est ce que nous proposera en
face on a un mot quelle est votre
ambition à vous sur la 11e
circonscription vous serez notamment
face à jean-michel fourgous et l'air
alors on rappelle le nom de votre
candidat vraiment certain brio ou du
front national quelle est votre ambition
dupont libéralisé - user - quiproquo
quelle est votre ambition pour le fonds
libérés c'est d'être élu ou c'est aussi
de vous implanter surtout localement
alors au politiquement a terminé on
espère toujours être élu mais on est on
est assez réaliste d'accord moi je
connais très bien la circonscription
je pense que sur cette sur le nombre de
candidats rejetés connaît pas tous donc
je veux pas juger mal mais en tout cas
vous êtes des gros candidats qui sont
considérés comme ça il ya effectivement
monsieur monsieur fourgous qui était un
ancien député qu'un candidat je pense
assez sérieux il y aurait pu y aurait pu
y avoir monsieur benoît hamon qui aurait
pu être un candidat sérieux mais qui
malheureusement a perdu 2,2 crédibilité
son score assez pathétique à l'élection
présidentielle est le fait surtout
d'avoir démissionné dieu de son mandat
de conseiller municipal
alors que c'est le cas ses modalités est
due à la peau mais voilà il était élu à
trappes et c'est le mandat le plus
proche des habitants
le plus le plus honorifique au très
rapidement parce qu'on est pris par le
temps les choses ambitions du coup vous
avez un ambitions chiffrées une
ambitions chiffrées ou alors vous verrez
bien commencé c'est difficile en par
deux on part de zéro c'est c'est
difficile de vous donner un chiffre
comme ça
je ne peux pas votre rythme alors dans
ce cas vous vous ferez campagne et vous
serez donc candidat sur la 11e
circonscription le 11 juin prochain
nicolas bauer vous êtes je rappelle le
suppléant de mireille brouillaud sur la
11e circonscription pour le front libéré
on va revoir peut-être sa fiche et les
candidats qui seront opposés à vous ils
seront douze autres convois justement
s'afficher à l'écran à l'instant merci
est ce que je peux dire juste alors tu
continue mon humour très rapidement
puisque le temps nous manque
voilà n'irait breugnot et moi même nous
sommes élus sur cette circonscription
on est donc nous implantés localement et
on est des candidats s'il savait
l'encours est élu à travers à merci
encore et puis bonne campagne avoue
plast merci à l'actualité de la semaine
et cette semaine a été marquée par la
grève d'une partie des salariés de
vortex l'entreprise prestataire du
conseil départemental pour le transport
des personnes à mobilité réduite à
notamment une agence et du en cours
suite à l'appel de plusieurs syndicats
les employés dénoncent leurs conditions
de travail et la volonté de la direction
de les faire travailler un samedi de
plus par mois
écoutez à ce propos le délégué du
personnel de voir texte lui en toi au
jour d'aujourd'hui ils ont ils se sont
présentés au marché
c'est un marché public au moins dix ans
c'est à dire pour obtenir le marché
il propose des coûts les plus bas
possible et ça se répercute sur le
salaire des gens et sur leurs conditions
de travail
aujourd'hui ils disent qu'on leur coupe
de l'argent or au jour d'aujourd'hui
quand il est répondu au marché il était
déjà en déficit
c'était pour couvrir des pertes qu'ils
avaient ailleurs qu'ils ont répondu au
marché ils ont obtenu ce marché ils
disent qu'on leur coupe de l'argent
quand ils ont répondu aux marchés
savaient très bien combien ça coûte et
le personnel et combien le coût de
gestion
donc ils pouvaient ils peuvent pas dire
qu'ils sont ignorants là dessus et pour
être tout à fait précis sur le sujet
sachez que les deux parties n'ont pas
trouvé de terrain d'entente
la grève d'une partie des salariés de
vortex reprendra dès lundi à guyancourt
du sport aussi dans l'actualité à cette
semaine avec handball la montée en
nationale 3 de l'équipe senior de
plaisir une accession à l'échelon
supérieur
attendu par les clubs depuis 13 ans les
plaisirs oit a joué il ya quelques jours
lors d'un match de championnat avec à la
clé une 20e victoire de la saison
les précisions avec ce sujet de michael
et demi d'euros plaisir termina plus
belle saison de son histoire par une
victoire assurée de monter pour la
première fois en nationale 3 les jaunes
est loin se sont imposés lors de
l'ultime journée contre draveil dans un
match sans enjeu le score 34 à 31
le base nous on n'aime pas perdre et on
voulait pour le dernier match à domicile
voilà une petite victoire propre public
c'était pas notre meilleur match loin de
là mais bon c'était n'était pas
l'important est plus important c'était
c'était vraiment il ya trois semaines
contre eux ou voilà on avait à coeur de
gagner celui là et là on l'a gagnée pour
le public mais pour nous voilà on a on
sait juste le plaisir va bien avec cette
victoire plaisir termine sa saison avec
un bilan de 20 victoires un nul et une
seule défaite
les statistiques affolantes qui ont
permis à l'équipe de terminer en tête de
prénationale à quatre points d'avancé
sur le second voyez athlétique
cette montée était attendue depuis 13
ans par les supporters donc je pense que
ça représente énormément pour le public
pour le club les anciens du club le tout
les dirigeants les bénévoles les petits
enfin c'est vraiment une grande famille
c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les 12 c'est vraiment un club qui avec
lui ce moment là tous ensemble et à
quand une chose c'est de faire la fête
avec eux ce soir après les festivités
les plaisirs or ont déjà les yeux rivés
sur la saison prochaine est l'objectif
numéro 1 le maintien faut tout de suite
se remettre au travail parce que va
falloir
tout au moins maintenir l'année
prochaine et puis travailler de manière
à pouvoir continuer à amener le projet
et c'est de mener le plus haut possible
donc le ca récent rapport mais avant de
penser à la saison prochaine place à la
fête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bonne saison et en culture cette
semaine la rédaction de tv fil 78 de
vous a présenté le travail de benjamin
ce parc un peintre et plasticien
franco-belge son inspiration le pop art
et l'actualité
une vision de ce qui se passe dans le
monde à travers des toiles très bdx et
oeuvres sont à découvrir jusqu'au 17
septembre à la maison triolet aragon à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines un sujet de
mélanie poké nicolas landry
des images très warholienne cinquante
ans plus tard le pop art se vit toujours
sous le pinceau de benjamin starke
l'artiste franco belge s'inspire de tout
ce qu'il voit le cinéma la publicité
le dessin de presse je fouine les images
fouine les informations je fouine ce que
les graphistes font les autres artistes
les cinéastes et j'essaie de me nourrir
un maximum de ça de toute cette culture
qui environnent pour ensuite créer des
montages des décollages et et essayer de
percevoir des éléments qui pourraient
coller ensemble qui pourrait commencer à
être un embryon de narration du noir du
blanc et de couleurs et des oeuvres sans
titre i pour laisser toute
l'interprétation regardeur comme il les
appelle pour porter une réflexion autour
d'un thème la violence
l'actualité du monde est tellement
dingue de toute façon que ça donne envie
de s'exprimer
on retrouve sur les tableaux ce qu'on
retrouve dans l'actualité des armes d
explosion de la violence et c'est un
exutoire c'est évidemment une première
façon d'appréhender la violence étant
particulièrement axé sur la non violence
sur la fin de la guerre au plus vite sur
l'arrêt immédiat des aides de
l'intervention de la france par exemple
où la belgique au moyen-orient
j'aimerais faire passer au moins ce
message là si je peux à travers ce genre
de tableaux l'artiste marie les
techniques d'aujourd'hui impression
laser et numériques logiciels
informatiques qui lient aux matières
nobles peintures toiles de lin doigt un
univers très actuel qui mêle un héritage
de bande dessinée
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo merci
de nous avoir suivis et retrouver toutes
nos séquences en replay sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]